y amar está a sólo unos metros detrás de
la alambrada en maestros una ciudad
fronteriza tailandesa los refugiados
birmanos saben que su tierra natal está
bloqueada por la junta desde el golpe de
estado
en tailandia son libres de decir lo que
piensan constituyen la mitad de la
población de esta comuna 60.000 personas
que hablan con una sola voz
todos llevan el signo de los tres dedos
que se ha convertido en el símbolo de
las revueltas asiáticas a favor de la
democracia
en el mercado de maíz 8 como en toda la
frontera
los inmigrantes mi hermanos están
enfadados decididos y más unidos que
nunca
todos los birmanos del mercado y sus
alrededores apoyan el movimiento de los
manifestantes cada uno contribuye de su
propio bolsillo y nosotros enviamos
dinero a mianmar para ayudarles apoyo
financiero pero también logístico y
digital en un patio trasero la
asociación de antiguos presos políticos
birmanos funciona casi clandestinamente
a salvo de los espías de la junta
birmana creada hace 20 años esta
organización registra en tiempo real
todas las violaciones de los derechos
humanos al otro lado de la frontera les
acaba de llegar un vídeo de una
violencia sin precedentes este grupo
está en la nómina del ejército están
atacando a estos manifestantes pacíficos
no podemos aceptar esto en nuestro país
debemos expulsar absolutamente al
ejército del sistema en los próximos
meses las cosas empeorarán habrá cada
vez más violencia detenciones y órdenes
de arresto contra los manifestantes
gracias a las nuevas tecnologías podemos
mostrar cosas que no podíamos mostrar en
1988 y es una gran oportunidad para
nosotros porque puede acercarnos a ganar
esta vez 1988 el año que cambió el curso
de la historia de mianmar y reveló aún
sanssouci al mundo este exiliado fue uno
de los estudiantes que en su momento se
opuso al ejército durante meses
resultado una represión ultra violenta
3000 muertos y 14 años de cárcel para él
hoy como muchos estudiantes de la
generación del 88 vuelve a la lucha
apoyando a los manifestantes
nosotros ex prisioneros políticos
estamos recogiendo firmas de todos los
inmigrantes birmanos para enviarlas a
todos los organismos internacionales que
se ocupan de las aspiraciones de los
derechos humanos
la única sentencia posible para los
generales es la soga y quiero ser yo
quien los cuelgue
hoy en los pueblos fronterizos otro
grupo apoya las protestas en mianmar son
los k en un grupo étnico de 5 millones
de personas en el este de mianmar
perseguidos durante décadas por la junta
muchos cruzan la frontera en busca de
tratamientos en tailandia en este centro
médico gestionado durante 30 años por
esta calle
así que nada
esta mujer llegó en octubre de 2019
justo antes del coi tiene tres niños y
ahora dos niños tenemos tres mil
trabajadores médicos operando en el este
de mianmar tienen acceso a una población
de 750 mil personas
de hecho para soñar con la paz y la
democracia debemos proteger los derechos
humanos e intentar resistir juntos al
ejército y devolver el poder al pueblo
el golpe actual está reavivando las
tensiones entre la junta y las
rebeliones étnicas que apoyan a los
manifestantes
la resistencia a karen con 5000
efectivos es la guerrilla más antigua
del mar
a pesar del alto el fuego desde 2011 los
abusos de los soldados birmanos contra
los karen nunca han cesado desde el
golpe de estado incluso se han
intensificado provocando un flujo de
refugiados internos para ayudar a este
grupo étnico o parcialmente cristiano
una ong evangelista estadounidense los
free burma rangers lleva 25 años
operando clandestinamente en mianmar
actualmente se encuentran en el corazón
de las selvas de karen en una zona
totalmente inaccesible conseguimos
llegar a ellos a través de una conexión
por satélite ayer lo primero que vimos
al acercarnos a un pueblo fueron los
niños escondidos en la selva el ejército
mi hermano comenzó a bombardear la aldea
los soldados y hermanos dispararon a una
niña que huía
las balas alcanzaron la espalda y la
cabeza murió al instante atacan a
civiles karen hombres mujeres niños
bebés pueblos disparando los para matar
el actual movimiento prodemocrático y la
represión de la junta no se limitan a
rangún y las principales ciudades toda
mi alma está afectada en esta pequeña
escuela los alumnos son birmanos los
niños y su profesor que han estado
trabajando duro en sus clases de dibujo
también están preocupados por lo que
ocurre al otro lado de la frontera un
sentimiento de preocupación pero sobre
todo de determinación yo estoy llamando
mi familia pero creo que han vuelto a
cortar internet hoy no he podido llegar
a ellos estoy preocupado
quiero ir a ayudar a los manifestantes
si puedo admiro a un samsung si es una
mujer fuerte trabajadora y valiente que
se preocupa por su pueblo en el futuro
si tuviera que hacerlo me gustaría ser
como ella
que lo sepan los generales birmanos la
próxima generación está dispuesta a
tomar la antorcha cueste lo que cueste